every morning i prepare myself for the
day i think failure is bad
i don't think it's good but if if
if something's important enough then you
do it even though the risk of failure is
high
we're asked about work-life balance all
the time and my view is that's a
debilitating phrase because
it um it implies there's a strict
trade-off
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven
billionaire habits that you must copy
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one have a good morning ritual with
oprah winfrey
every morning i prepare myself for the
day
so i listen to some form of either a
spiritual song
or i read some kind of spiritual passage
i do i read something called the bowl of
saki which is written by a
a sufi master or i'll read a daily word
and then i i meditate
and i do a gratitude um journal
and whether i'm doing it electronically
or whether i'm you know writing in my
little journal that i can i don't carry
the journal around if i'm going to be on
longest in vacations because once i left
the journal in a hotel
and god only knows what you could sell
that for so i don't do that
but i i keep uh some form of spiritual
practice
where i remind myself daily
of where i've come from how about number
two build work
life harmony with jeff bezos with regard
to your personal lifestyle there are no
guilty pleasures that you are
doing unreasonable things with i don't
think they're that guilty i mean i
i um i have lots of pleasures and you
know
um we just came back from an amazing uh
trip uh with the kids mckenzie and i did
she planned the whole thing it was her
birthday trip but she planned it all we
went to
norway for three days and we stayed in
an ice hotel
um we went dog sledding we uh
we uh went to a wolf preserve
and actually got to interact with you
know these timberwolves
i mean it was really an incredible
vacation an incredible holiday and all
we got it all done in three and a half
days
so it was really it was amazing this
work-life harmony thing is what i
try to teach young employees actually
and senior executives at amazon too but
especially the people coming i get we're
asked about work life balance all the
time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because it it implies there's a strict
trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy
and so it actually is a circle it's not
a balance
and and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody paying attention to
habit number three
be willing to take risks with elon musk
you've also said that failure was the
most
likely outcome can you talk about
failure in that sense and in a broader
sense of
being an entrepreneur and an innovator
why is failure so important
uh well i mean i think i think failure
is bad
um i don't think it's good um but if
if something's important enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome
is is that it's not going to work and
they should reconcile themselves to that
past strong possibility um and they
should only do it if they feel that
they're
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know
because it's it's it's gonna the way
starting company works is like
usually in the beginning it's the very
beginning it's kind of fun um
and then it's really hellish for for a
number of years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine whose
successful entrepreneur and
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name is bully uh he
said yeah
your starting company is like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
and and you agree with that generally
true
um yeah and and and
if you don't eat the glass you're not
going to be successful also if you want
to have more self belief and self
confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day for
254 days the research says it can take
up to 254 days for you to build a new
habit and this program will help you get
it once again it's free and the link to
join is in the description below
key to success is what you believe
is true for yourself if everything has
to work in two to three years
then that limits what you can do before
we were able to get the roadster out
then they'd say well you couldn't
possibly make that car work
habit number four take care of your body
and mind with warren buffett
70 years ago i was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when i was in high school i really
only had two things on my mind
girls and cars and and i wasn't doing
very well with girls so we'll talk about
cars
but let's just imagine that when we
finish
i'm going to let each one of you pick
out
the car of your choice sounds good
doesn't it
pick it out any color you name it it'll
be tied up with a bow
and it'll be at your house tomorrow
and you say well what's the catch
and the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime
now what are you going to do knowing
that that's the only car
you're ever going to have and you love
that car you're going to take care of it
like you cannot believe now what i'd
like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime
but you're going to get one body and one
mind and that's all you're going to get
and that body and mind feels terrific
now
but it has to last you a lifetime habit
number five
is hustle with sarah blakely i feel like
hustle is
um the willingness to work really really
hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like
kind of navigating and doing what it
takes
and um and so
i i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome
or my success be contingent on
other people as much as i can control it
help it
navigate it i'm going to so um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now i mean obviously i'm hustling
i'm like at
at this where i am now and i'm running
around the airport asking people to
follow me on instagram you know
uh i just feel like it's innate in me
also to a degree
um but the uh in the beginning
ex like there's a few examples that come
to mind you mentioned that i
paid my i called my friends and asked
them to go buy spanx and i
wrote everybody checks and sent them a
check um
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i need to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that
my product was in the sleepiest part of
the department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there
so then i immediately
went to target and i bought
envelope dividing dividers that you put
on your home desk
and i ran around neiman marcus and put
them at every register
and i put spanx in them and then i
walked away
and neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and and i did that
because i had to get my product out of
the department and because i did that
women in
shoes started buying spanx and women in
contemporary
and um those decisions made such a big
difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it
because you know everybody thought
somebody else approved it um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it
habit number six look for your gifts
with mark
cuban my dad busted his ass i mean he
worked
six six days a week um lit left at seven
at seven seven thirty in the morning got
back at six or seven o'clock
um lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting
um um some
covering on a car seat um you know it
was it was a middle-class upbringing my
mom
did odd jobs you know they they just
wanted something better i mean my
grandparents came over from russia and
you know my dad was the first generation
my uncles were the first generation
americans
like my mom too and you know like every
child of immigrants they wanted better
for their kids
you know it's funny i mean a lot of
people grow up that way right but not
many people end up like you so
what do you think that's the result of i
think
you know everybody's got something that
they're good at and the hard part is
just finding it
and i found out early that i was a good
salesperson that i really liked business
you know like i like sports i mean i
read everything i possibly could played
sports as much as i could
just wasn't as good as i wanted to be
and and business was the same way i mean
as long as i could remember
i was buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps um to
collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and
you know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read
about ted turner than go to the movies
and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i have my ups and downs along the way of
course but um
i just think that i just i just put in
the time and
was fortunate enough to really get
excited about business and that paid off
benefits over the long haul
and habit number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is be realistic with michael bloomberg
in the past you could make a decision
had some time to work it out
fix it change it build a constituency
demonstrate
your wisdom and today we want instant
gratification you've got to know
is it going to work and then we're we've
gotten 10 000 emails 20 seconds later
so that's it's not working it's like
complaining about i have an iphone 6.
and iphone is just an amazing device
and people are complaining if you sit on
it it bends
now if i took a mac computer and threw
it out of a
five-story window it would break
okay so what i mean we just
we we don't have any tolerance
everybody's a talking head everybody's
got an idea
and and one of the problems in life is
sort of sorting out
what is realistic what is real what is
factual
uh what is put in context and social
media
isn't designed to do that social media
is designed to let everybody talk to
everybody all the time
and to me that means you have to have
the old values we don't have to teach
our kids to code as much as we have to
teach them to read to write to do
arithmetic
to understand that numbers are just
another language and how to
speak that language that you're going to
have to work collaboratively and
collectively
and you're not going to turn this all
over to technology and if you do
nobody's going to have a job
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you gonna
take
action on it this week when you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're gonna take action you have
a 91 chance of actually following
through
versus just a 35 chance if you just got
motivated but never created a specific
plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
i love to say this especially to
entrepreneurs one of the great secrets
in life
to becoming successful whether it's in a
business
whether it's working with someone or for
someone or in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedias
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection it comes you don't get turned
off you don't get disappointed like well
i'm not going to do this anymore no one
thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
they slam them in your face you must be
just as enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
and that's what the real secrets and
growing up as kids in downtown l.a
we all knew that we didn't have a lot we
noticed a lot of things going to turn
you
down at seven trying to sell a flower
pot on the street
most people said no but it's only 50
cents no no no
sooner a waitress a little restaurant
said
only 50 cents that's really great she
bought it from us
and we went built another one
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below
or if you want to learn some of the best
lessons from billionaire entrepreneurs
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there